beijing asks alibaba to [ __ ] its media
assets china's government has asked
alibaba to dispose of its media assets
as officials grow more concerned about
the technology giants
sway over public opinion in the country
hello
discussions over the matter have been
held early since early this year after
chinese regulators reviewed a
list of media assets owned by alibaba
whose main state businesses as online
retail officials were appalled at how
expansive alibaba's media interests have
become and asked the company to come up
with a plan to substantially curtail
its media holdings alibaba has uh
throughout the years assembled a
formidable portfolio media assets that
span
print broadcast digital social media and
advertising notable holdings include
stakes in twitter like weibo platform
several popular chinese
digital and print news outlets as well
as south china's morning post a leading
english newspaper
uh english language newspaper in hong
kong several of these holdings are
in u.s listed companies such influences
seen as posing serious challenge to the
chinese
communist party and its powerful
propaganda
apparent apparent uh say the word right
there a pair
apparent apparatus okay so thoughts on
china
dude i mean they're not even freaking
hiding it
at this point like it's not even like
well i wonder what they're doing
i mean there's a smoking gun right here
they're basically saying there's no free
press
there's no [ __ ] first amendment here
in china there's no
you know free speech they are completely
curtailing it they're seeing what's
happening
you know especially on the social media
side of things big tech
in the us and they're saying hell no we
are not allowing that here in china the
ccp
controls that i think that's pretty it's
pretty funny that they quote unquote
asked alibaba to dispose of its media
assets and
uh asked the company to come up with a
plan
to substantially curtail its media
holdings and they were quote unquote
appalled at how expansive alibaba's
media interests are
they said get your ass in the
principal's office sit in the chair
do what the hell i'm gonna have you do
or you're gonna go and end up like jack
ma at a re-education camp and not be
seen
for a couple months i mean this is the
biggest difference when we talk about
china's you know potentially being the
number one economy in the world and
they're going to
surpass united states be careful what
you wish for
with china leading the way for the rest
of the world
it's not a democracy it's an autocracy
they don't give two f's what the people
have to say
so if you're cool with 1.5 billion
robots
following what xi jinping basically
decrees
then go have at it in china but nobody
wakes up and says
one of these days i'm gonna make it to
china and i'm gonna live a better life
in china
hell no that's still america's place on
the planet so we need to recognize that
uh i think bill maher said something
like this he said something like there's
got to be something in between
you know an authoritarian government
that tells everyone what to do
and a representative government that
can't do anything at all
so an author authoritarian government
like in china will tell you what to do
and you know we're
we're fighting between amongst ourselves
here in america
we got to do better but china is not the
direction we want to frickin go
and that's a case example right there
that they're not even allowing
immediate you know a big time company to
quote unquote voice our opinion this
would be like saying jeff bezos
because jack ma is basically the jeff
bezos of china
that's the best analogy and what
uh publication does did jeff bezos buy
the washington post
right and he has the freedom to do
whatever the hell he wants in the
washington post
you want to go liberal with it go live
with it bro you want to get more
conservative
go get conservative with it but do what
you want to do but not in china
sorry jack ma sorry uh simon hugh
sorry eric jing these people that are
running ant group and uh alibaba
you're gonna follow our lead or get the
hell out of the way and go to your
re-education camp
is this a forecast to what's going on in
america and they're canceling their
media assets
what's going on over here in america
canceling twitter accounts canceling our
freedom of speech
you know every time i reflect back on my
military experience two deployments with
the 15 marine expeditionary unit and
every time i
travel across the world on these
deployments how much i appreciated
america
how much more i said you know what
america is a great place to be we got
roads we got this we can things that we
can't we we can say
easily here in america i think a lot of
people take for granted
because you try that type of stuff in
china you're done
you talked about the jack ma and the
origi education camp where is jack
matthews you know
you know where is a lot of characters at
you know where is jack
ma you know where's jimmy hoffa where's
jack ma
and so when you when you're looking at
america you know i i
that social experiment we talked about a
minute ago where
coming out of high school wouldn't this
be an
amazing type of social experiment that
before going to college take a
chapter out of the mormon uh playbook
there serve
for two years yeah serve either the
military
do public service do a a non-profit
organization for two years see how much
you appreciate the rest of the world
then come back to america talk to me
about how much you don't like it over
here
my thoughts that's powerful to be
thinking about then both of you guys
made a lot of good points but i will
tell you one thing here
kudos to bill maher bill maher's been
pushing the envelope a lot lately bill
maher's been saying hey don't join this
cancer culture hey
you liberals out there and he's he's a
hardcore liberal doesn't believe in god
religiously the documentary video that
he did he went to religiously yeah so
religiously so so i i respect a lot of
bill maher today
you know i think the the other day i was
having a conversation with gerard herron
he's a comedian out of new york and
gerard used to be part of the team you
remember gerard g big g oh yeah
he was part of the team and you know he
was talking about
he says this era eliminates rodney
dangerfield
it eliminates tim allen eliminates all
the
famous seinfeld eliminates a lot of the
legendary
republican and independent comedians you
have to be very careful today because
there's an audience of 100 million
people
that like the conservative comedian that
like that jokes that they make right
you can't have those comedians today so
why are they getting their comedy today
right why did
why should they not have the competition
today it's a dangerous place to go
but today more than ever bill mars are
important by the way
by the way there is no bill mark without
hbo
so you have to give some credence and
respect to the fact that hbo hasn't
canceled billboard
right it's not like bill maher says
diplomatic politically correct things
bill maher goes off to charts and he
says some stuff
you've never heard hbo saying we're
going to cancel bill maher they've stuck
to
bill maher respect for by the way hbo
will do hardcore socialist
documentaries and shows they'll do
center they'll go right they'll go
i mean obviously they're a little bit
more left and they're they're on the
right
but still you know they leave bill alone
they don't say hey you cannot say
something like that and we say dude
no no bill is bill maher right i think
we need more bill mars we need more jon
stewart's today
we need more guys like that that are
being vocal because or else
the next thing we're looking at is what
a china situation what they got going on
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye